now to televise mental institution known
as MSNBC they had historian presidential
historian Michael beschlas on and he
thinks Trump's on his way to becoming a
dictator yep that's right the guy who's
under indictment for like 87 things and
four billion counts of this and that
he's the dictator
you know as Lawrence O'Donnell said uh
Michael beschlas
Donald Trump holds the ultimate
incentive for her meaning he becomes
president Clarence Thomas retires to
permanently vacation with his
billionaire friends who by the way
probably won't want to take him anywhere
anymore because they can't give him
anything anymore and she gets on the
Supreme Court in her late 30s and then
she had there's no incentive for her to
behave herself if she's Maga she can
Maga and there's nothing we can do about
it well and the other thing is we have
to ask the question just as Josh was
saying why did Donald Trump choose this
moment to tell the American people that
he will become a dictator if elected you
might think it might be more politically
shrewd to pretend to be a moderate and
then do all this if he is elected and I
would give two reasons the major reason
is if Americans think that Donald Trump
is inevitable and that fascism is the
wave of the American future people will
begin in their minds to censor
themselves and they will make
adjustments and everything they do
between now and 16 months from now at
the time of the election they might say
well maybe I shouldn't say this because
if Trump is reelected he may start
jailing people he may retaliate against
people and very specifically if Donald
Trump right now wants to intimidate
jurors
in Fort Pierce Florida in Georgia in
Washington D.C in other trials you know
what better way than to give them the
idea that if they're if they are cast a
vote that sends Donald Trump to prison
or causes him to be convicted then if
Donald Trump becomes president who's
going to be first on the enemies list
remember what President Obama said when
we lose true democracy people get hurt
that's what's going to happen if this
happens
did Donald Trump tell the people he'll
become a dictator if elected do we
Phoenix did we drop the clip on that one
the Donald Trump I'm going to be a
dictator clip did Brock are you uh
you're on the computer a lot did we ever
see the Donald Trump I'm going to become
a dictator clip
and we we try we're doing the best we
can over here these people are
absolutely nuts but it continues with
this specialist guy who's supposed to be
again he's supposed to be a presidential
historian right he's supposed to give
perspective related to previous
administrations and the personalities
and behind the scenes what makes a
president and an Administration go and
all of that stuff but he's mostly a
Democrat activist right and you've got
the front runner of the Republican Party
Donald Trump the number two candidate by
polls Ron DeSantis or D status or
whatever it is
they're both fascists they both want
authoritarianism in America
we try to get Michael bachel on the show
I want to have him emailed absolutely
today what an embarrassing pathetic
human being he is their fascists Donald
Trump who's now under sham indictments
is the fascist Ron DeSantis who fought
corporations working with governments
against the will of the people he's the
fascist he was fighting fascism you
[Music]